Emily was cooking for me meanwhile I'm
like okay Emily my mom's gonna cook for
you I'm gonna lightly help
my mom was like all over that the way
Emily was but meanwhile I'm like I'm
like kind of giving my Mom's Tips I'm
like less sauce less sauce hey guys I'm
Lex I'm Emily I am of Italian descent
I'm Dominican and she's like girl you
gotta try my Dominican spaghetti and I
was like and I absolutely do
we eat very Italian in my house with the
lactose intolerant I always wonder how
because you can't make an Italian
lactose top I got your house your mom
had like all of the ingredients like
prepped out regular spaghetti it's just
like tomato sauce pasta and like your
meatballs you add a little parmesan
cheese on top like whatever you want but
that's really it I walk in she's got
olives we got onions out there
you let that spaghetti cook for I'm not
kidding you like 20 minutes though
it's the consistency of it is not Al
Dente anymore I've read that like you
can't break the pasta you could not what
happens when you break the pasta what
happened to the Italian culture you
break your Nona's heart
we had like meatballs with it too
so yeah I made those not a good cook but
you are you were so disgusted this is so
gross I I can't explain enough how much
I hate this just so we're all fear but
the meatballs were really good and if
you do get married they will like your
meatballs because I hope I like theirs
stop it hey the color of how it was
after they came out of the oven like I
was just we don't have meatballs in our
spaghetti she was like we're gonna have
meatballs meatballs oh yeah our salami
probably because we had salami in the in
the Dominican spaghetti and that is like
equivalent I guess to the meatball
the pasta sauce I think that like seeing
how much care your mom put into it Mom's
concerned she's gonna burn herself
wow it's coming yeah and like all of the
ingredients and measuring it like we
were not measuring at my house like we
were just like okay that I think that's
okay but your mom was like no it needs
this specific amount of garlic I was
gonna say because like you don't want
you can't eyeball garlic okay what if I
have a date I mean mom doesn't think
that I ever can get one but like God
forbid I finally get a date and I go out
with garlic
and then what I liked about your
spaghetti like after seeing it all
together
the sauce is set to the side us we don't
do that we're like we're gonna add as
much sauce as we want like we're gonna
add as much green peppers onions
green olives she's making me hungry
fried salami and then we added tostones
my mom was like oh do you guys
we have it for like afternoon Saturday
lunch kind of thing and there's always
the stones there's always always always
always those donuts which the arto stone
is is garlic bread but it's oh my God we
didn't have garlic bread I meant to make
garlic bread I forgot I think that they
both like kind of had they were so
different that they almost have like a
time and a place for each type of thing
like they're not really comparable
almost
foreign
I would give it a 10 out of 10. because
I saw those spices in there
I saw the color of everything the color
of the sauce the texture of the pasta
and I actually liked Al Dente like I was
surprised at myself so she likes how
pasta's supposed to be I'm so proud oh
my gosh
um I loved yours actually I I feel like
I'm gonna get a lot of flack as an
Italian for liking another like
spaghetti but I'm gonna be that mad
disrespectful then for a second and say
I really freaking enjoyed their
spaghetti
it's pretty freaking good
really yeah
yeah it was really good my parents even
ate it too and they both really liked it
it's delicious it's not tomatoey like
you said it's got like a pepper and meat
flavor to it
but it's delicious and I would
definitely eat this again I would go to
a restaurant and order this yes for sure
I sent likes a video of my parents
eating the pasta they loved it
wow
very good very natural
and we gave each other wine yeah we do
that yeah my mom was like bring bring
something
um
[Music]
in the Italian culture the heart of your
home is your kitchen the other rooms the
house are almost decoration and it's a
it's a whole family ordeal like when my
mom was cooking even if it's just her
like it's not like I just left her alone
I do agree that everything happens in
the kitchen yeah um at my house
it happens at your house and I'm just
glad I was able to experience it with
you because it was special like it was
really special it was what I love about
this is it's my culture but it's like my
emphasis on my and same thing with yours
like it's your culture but it's emphasis
on like your aspect of it be able to
share that with you and then have you
like it it was so cool I love it but I
think that me and Emily might want to
swap some more so if you guys what
should we do let us know some other
foods that you would like to see us Swap
and thanks for joining literally bye
guys